Так Олександр Думишинець проводить час зі своєю донькою Соломією.
Часто приєднується і його дружина Христина.
Вони майже разом. Але це не так.
Він удома в Києві, а вони за тисячі кілометрів.
Коли я з ними розмовляю, я начебто поруч. Так.
Але коли я вішаю трубку, я розумію, я дивлюсь навколо
- і розумію, що не поруч.
Олександр не може виїхати з країни через воєнний стан.
А його родина в безпечній Шотландії.
Там у них новий будинок, нова школа, нові друзі та нова мова.
Їм доводиться будувати нове життя.
Без нього.
По телебаченню, ми бачимо в інтернеті - сім'ї розходяться,
тому що складно, важко. Можливо, нам вдається, бо ми навколо Соломійки
об’єднуємось, розуміємо для чого це.
Олександр намагається стежити за успіхами Соломії в школі
за допомогою відео, які їй надсилають вчителі.
Вони навіть відвідали його в жовтні минулого року.
Але світло їхнього спільного буття затьмарили атаки
російських безпілотників на Київ.
Єдине, про що я в той момент молився, щоб вони виїхали.
Тому що тоді було дуже страшно. І коли ти дивишся на ситуацію,
що тут відбувається і що краще для дитини, то цим жертвуєш.
Оскільки війна триває, їхня розлука починає здаватися
менш тимчасовою. Спочатку Олександр думав, що їм просто
доведеться провести 12 місяців окремо. Але тепер він погодився,
що принаймні на наступний навчальний рік для Соломії
краще залишитися в Шотландії.
Коли ми поїхали на місяць, на два. Це так наче це така відпустка.
І є таке, що я повернуся. Тобто я там не кидаю корені,
нічого там не узнаю, дітей ще нікуди не веду.
А коли у мене там пів року, коли рік, я якось повинна жити.
І я дітей веду в садочок, веду в школу, вони там вже пристосовуються.
І тому чим довше вони там будуть, тим важче їм буде повертатися.
Елла Лібанова десятиліттями досліджує соціально-демографічні проблеми.
Вона хвилюється, що чим довше триватиме війна, тим більше
вкорінюватимуться діти та їхні матері у нових домівках.
Після війни повернення в зруйновану країну може здатися
невдалим варіантом. А багато біженців - це саме ті люди,
які будуть потрібні Україні.
70 відсотків жінок, які виїхали після 24 лютого, мають вищу освіту.
Ви прекрасно розумієте, що якщо дружина має вищу освіту,
то чоловік, швидше за все, також. Тобто ми втратимо
дуже значну частину людського та соціального капіталу.
Щоб підтримувати зв’язок із донькою, Олександр читає казки на ніч.
Важливо, перш за все, щоб не розривався цей зв’язок між нами,
щоб не створювалось якоїсь прірви.
Спілкуємося зранку, протягом дня і ввечері
обов’язково лягаємо спати разом.
Діти бояться того, що їх кинули, що папа десь.
І коли дитина папу бачить, коли є казки, то це дуже добре.
Але не всі папи можуть читати казки, бо вони можуть бути на фронті
і там не до казок. Але вони можуть просто писати щось: як ти?
Можуть домовитись про якесь там слово, яке вони пишуть,
коли все добре. Я тебе люблю і обов'язково пишуть.
Є тати, які можуть якесь маленьке відео зробити і дитині надіслати.
А дитина може щось малювати.
Для папи і вони це люблять робити.
І вони можуть розказувати на диктофон і папі надсилати.
Сьогодні ввечері Олександр читає донці дитячі вірші
українського письменника Володимира Вакуленка.
Він загинув на війні - але його слова нагадають
маленькій Соломії, звідки вона родом.